okay so this is a wool feel and as
anything named after a wolf would
suggest they are intimidating master
predators you may see the way this guy
chomps down on a sea urchin like it just
doesn't even feel its spines on its
throat his teeth are pretty worn down
from years after eating stuff like that
including this unfortunate crab wolf
eels are about seven feet long and they
live in the North Pacific look at the
way it just kind of swims through the
water it's kind of enough captivating
mesmerizing then there's this wolf eel
and its mate she's the reddish female
you see here they're about to be parents
to an army of baby eels they kind of
look like alien spawn the female can lay
up to ten thousand eggs but what's
unique is that both parents will try to
ensure that as many of their adorable
little demon offspring survive as
possible
wolf eels are attentive parents both of
them will guard the eggs from danger
they take turns while one stays behind
and guards the eggs the other goes out
to hunt for delicious delicious crabs it
is believed that the wolf eels will mate
for life
now isn't that that's just nice you know
it's nice to hear that and they will
live in the same den for years unless
forced out by larger more horrifying
heels but anyway can can the producers
of this show just let me read a nice
butterfly script or something next time
I feel like I'm just getting all of the
horrifying creatures that are gonna
haunt my dreams
[Music]